I judge myself so much on not being
happy all the time because I thought
there was something wrong with the fact
that I wasn't happy that I drove myself
insane not being happy rather than just
being like you know what maybe I'm just
going to do the stuff and just [ __ ]
happiness for a minute it's like an
appreciation of The Human Experience
even in the suffering there's Beauty in
that because it's purely human I think
it's just understanding both sides of
the coin like if there's few things that
I believe it is that right now there are
things in my life that I don't like that
I wish for better and there are things
in my life that I really liked 10 years
ago it was the same way and 10 years
from now it'll be the same way and when
I die there will be stuff that I will
not have accomplished that I will wish I
had there will be things that I wish I
had done better that I will not have
done and there will be things that I
have done that I am proud of those
things are not going to change and so
all I can do is just enjoy the game and
it took me a really long time to get
there or at least it felt like I
suffered a lot on that process and so I
think it's like when we have these am I
happy am I not happy you have to rise
above it so that you can just feel the
Spectrum which is just being present if
I can just be present even in my
suffering then I can experience joy for
being human and having this experience
that I only get once